what's up you guys it's your girl megan
good and i am here with buzzfeed celeb
now i am getting ready to take a quiz
to tell me which megan good character i
actually
am
how would your friends describe you
optimistic
witty reliable creative honest
daring i think i'm gonna go with
optimistic because
i tend to be a person who likes to
always look for the silver lining and
likes to have a
positive attitude and outlook i don't
like anyone else to
feel bad or to feel sad or to think the
negative and so i try to encourage them
sometimes you shift things in that
direction so see even me saying that
sometimes
you shift things in that direction is me
being optimistic pick a former co-star
to go to lunch with
robert richard gabriel union kevin hart
lisa bonet will ferro angela bassett
i am gonna go with robert rashad my
first kind of like
big role um on the tv show was cousin
skeeter
and that's the show where i really grew
up and that really was like my childhood
and my teenage years and
robert is like a brother to me and no
matter what he'll have such a big
part of like those years of just like me
being a young person and
us being young we're just like in the
industry and just trying to like learn
life and so
he'll always be my brother and he's also
getting ready to guest star
on my new tv show with amazon so i'm
gonna go robert
pick some post-covered plans traveling
the world
spending time with family and friends
going on a restaurant tour
dancing all night at the best clubs
staying inside for a little longer
throwing away all of my masks i'm gonna
have to go with traveling the world
i actually like airports i actually like
being on planes i don't mind like 11
13-hour flights and like to get to go
somewhere special
like i just would love to travel and i
think that's one of the things that i
miss most
is having that freedom choose a
hairstyle we've got my goddess locks
we've got my bob with body we've got the
bang
the curls for the girls and we've got
the lady in red
and the blonde bombshell i know i think
i'm gonna go for the blonde bombshell
even though
it's really hard because the goddess
locks is probably the style i wear the
most
and probably the one of the ones i love
the most but i miss my blonde
so blonde bombshell pick a movie genre
to star in
rom-com historical drama thriller
musical animated action i'm gonna go
with action
um because i've been dying to do more
action even though thrillers like are
really really close
and so is historical drama and so is
animated i'm gonna go with action
because i
think that's what i really want to do
really bad now pick a tv show to binge
the crown black mirror elite big mouth
grand army the queen's gambit i'm gonna
go with elite
there was just so much drama and so much
craziness going on in that show and i
loved it and it was wild so
elite it is lastly which app could you
do without instagram twitter tick tock
pinterest facebook zoom i'm gonna go
with pinterest because i never use it
you got nina jones from cousins feeder
your personality matches nina jones like
nina
you're intelligent and witty you prefer
order
and organization rather than spontaneity
and chaos
you can be a little shy at times but
once you're out of your shell your
presence is undeniable
i do prefer organization i am a little
bit ocd but i actually enjoy
spontaneity and a little bit of chaos
this friday
i have a new film coming out called
monster hunter
and i also have my directorial debut my
co-directorial debut
this film is called if not now when it's
my throwback to
the films that really encouraged and
inspired me growing up the type of films
like waiting to excel that
i saw myself for the first time and i
suddenly became innately aware of my
worth this is kind of our our film to
you
into this generation and go out and see
it comes out january 8th
and it'll also be available in your
homes thanks guys for the support love
you all god bless
stay safe
[Music]
you